francis carole bonjour bonjour et bon
joueur celles et à ceux qui nous font
l'honneur de nous écouter et de nouveau
gardien alors vous avez décidé de vous
présenter pour les élections municipales
à à fort de france
d'ailleurs le nom de votre groupe et
peut-être de la liste ne changera pas
c'est le mouvement fox a changé faute
france alors francis carole certains
peuvent penser une énième candidature
alors même que vous avez encore du pain
sur la planche certainement à la ctm
puisque on le rappelle vous êtes
conseiller exécutif à la collectivité
territoriale alors très bien
je voudrais dire que simplement que je
n'ai pas attendu d'avoir ces 14 60 ans
pour défier la citadelle faut y aller ça
et si je veux j'ai ce palmarès ci ont pu
dire c'est parce que très tôt je n'avais
pas de concept a alors qu'il y avait un
fort leur assurer un climat de violence
et qu'il était difficile pour les camps
de l'opposition de s'exprimer
et bien moi j'ai pris le parti de me
présenter à l'époque contre 6 heures je
le dis je n'avais pas 37 ans et j'ai
continué à me battre parce que et il
faut se battre à fort de france j'ai été
élu conseiller général de fo le france
ne le plus gros carton de fort-de-france
le 7e canton
et puis j'ai continué le travail je ne
suis pas je me suis présenté en 2001
marie jeanne se présenter en même temps
en 2008 je ne me suis pas présentée et
je me suis présenté à 2014 et à 2014
nous avons fait un bond considérable
puisque nous avons plus 2004 savoir nous
étions à moins de 4000 voix de l'actuel
et maire qui a été élu parce que les
modalités d'élection avait changé à
savoir il suffit d'avoir la majorité
aujourd'hui pour pour passer alors
qu'avant il fallait avoir 27% des
escrocs et donc par conséquent je
revendique ce pas au co si t'es pas au
cours de combats est une ville qui n'est
pas une ville comme toutes les autres et
il fallait et des gens des hommes des
pouilles aller le résultat ce résultat
auquel vous avez fait allusion de 2014
vous avez considéré que c'est un
résultat finalement encourageant c'est
que nous allons battre a aussi motivé
résultat important d'autant que dans
beaucoup de quartiers et ça s'est
confirmé lors des élections
territoriales de 2010 doit beaucoup de
quartiers de fort-de-france
nous avons battu le ppm ce qui est une
chose nouvelle et je rappelle que nous
sommes la seule équipe à avoir battu le
ppm à deux reprises à fort de france
lors des élections cantonales
par conséquent je ne vais pas les mains
vides j'ai fait allusion à votre mandat
de conseiller territorial et vous êtes à
l'exécutif ça veut dire que si vous êtes
élu l'année prochaine vous il va vous
falloir céder ce mandat vous pourrez pas
cumuler le mandat de faire on ne peut
pas cumuler les deux mots dame
donc c'est un choix quand même clair que
vous faites là nettoyage et savent très
bien les foyalais il faut y aller sauf
que bien que je ne suis engagé dans la
bataille pour conquérir la ville de fort
de france de plus de 15 autres ça ne
date pas d'aujourd'hui
nous serons en 2020 à un an de la fin de
mandat de de la collectivité
territoriale et donc de mon mandat de
conseiller de l'itif or je considère que
s'il ya une plus haute et politique pour
moi dans ce que je souhaite faire c'est
la ville de fort de france alors francis
carole on va rassembler les deux
questions en fait un bel sont liés si
vous êtes donc élu maire quelle sera
votre première priorité en tant que
maire par rapport à la municipalité sa
situation les leviers de commande des
manettes et par rapport à cette ville
aussi à sa population et son bien-être
son développement économique et social
j'utiliserai le mot confiance n'a pas ce
que c'est ça la priorité ramener la
confiance
ramener la confiance entre le maire elle
ran ample ramener la confiance des gens
n'a pas lance mon jeu parce qu'il n'y en
a pas sinon nous sommes certains qu'il
n'a pas ramené la confiance entre le
maire et le personnel de la mairie qui
est un élément indispensable de réussite
des politiques que nous devons engager
mais ramener la confiance aussi entre
les faits à l'aise les fouilles à l'est
et la municipalité et parce que c'est
très important c'est ce que nous allons
nous attacher à faire dans un premier
temps alors qu'elle est
finalement quel est le dossier le plus
urgent alors on sait qu'il ya bon on a
beaucoup parlé de la situation
financière de la ville de fort de france
est ce que c'est par ce bout là vous
allez prendre les choses
où est ce que la question financière est
la question des moyens
les questions essentielles ça détermine
beaucoup de sens littéral beaucoup de
choses les questions essentielles sont
des questions qui sont liées au
bien-être de la population à la bonne
prise en charge des cas aussi à la
propreté de la ville à faire en sorte
que le centre ville et on reçoive des
gens alors que nous observons que
beaucoup de commerçants
beaucoup de gens bien intentionnés qui
ont envie de faire bouger les choses et
bien sont découragés parce que les
bonnes initiatives vous sont pas prises
on vous dit de venir aux islamises
économique alors vous dites que d'une
manière ou d'une autre vous trouverez
les moyens de faire tout ça d'avoir un
certain nombre d'attentions de projet il
faudrait moyens il faudra bien entendu
hiérarchiser les choses parce que ça
c'est très important pour la riera chez
les choses mais je pense que tout ce qui
est de la vitalité économique du
centre-ville
c'est essentiel et tout ce qui est de la
vie démocratique est aussi essentiel
c'est pourquoi les conseils de quartier
le référendum d'initiative populaire
tout c est toutes ces questions seront
central dans la démarche que nous
voulons mettre en oeuvre pour que fort
de france respire enfin on peut pas
rester avec la même équipe pendant près
de 80 ans merci francis carole d'avoir
répondu à nos questions dans sa aux
cadis spécial municipal émission
réalisée par patrice à la glisse à la
chaire séjourné à toutes et à tous